it's just two weeks since poland became
a beacon of sanctuary for ukrainian
refugees
now by their own admission the capital
warsaw is just about coping and close to
being overwhelmed
at the central station a sea of people
some just off trains from ukraine hungry
thirsty and tired
but the refugees are grateful to
volunteers for the most basic of things
like a toothbrush and helping them get
back on their feet
i had to
change the money for her because there
is a queue so we have to go and take the
tickets you've got a lot of people that
you need to help
as you can see
just not stopping is it it's not well it
is it's just i don't know how long it's
going to be but probably for a long time
warsaw has welcomed the equivalent of 15
of its previous population and nobody
knows how many are staying
where do you plan to go to we don't know
we don't know
no idea
no
idea no no
having arrived safely from ukraine the
refugees then need somewhere to go or
stay
these people are queuing for a bus for
germany they have no idea when it will
leave or even which city they'll end up
in
some have slept rough for days waiting
for somewhere else to go
others like gregory and his 87 year old
mother who can barely walk just want to
reach a european country where they have
friends
we have no
[Music]
home we have no
cars we have no nothing only these three
baggages oh that's all
this family would like to go to the uk
but aren't eligible as they have no
family ties but they can see the
pressure mounting on the authorities in
warsaw
we are going to germany because too much
our citizens in poland we don't we don't
want to bother poland
people
warsaw says it needs help calling on the
rest of europe and the uk to step up
i am afraid that this is just a
beginning
so i think you could
today think about
your offer for them if you could provide
something it would be really welcome
the refugee crisis is getting worse by
the day which means it's likely to be a
long time before any of these people
truly find some peace
lisa holland sky news warsaw